burne calling the Secretary of Treasury
secretary minutiae he got the call and I
got the second call and we made it
happen with all of their support and
this is great leadership and we're
looking forward to having several months
to position this coin to benefit a very
worthy cause the Smithsonian years ago
well I think it has started out with you
nominating Keiko James and then of
course we assembly assembled a wonderful
team please know I was just gonna say
thank you it has been an honor to be
your representative on this commission
but one of the things that's most
noteworthy is that we have worked
together in such a bipartisan way to
celebrate women's suffrage and the right
to vote in this country and I'm sorry
Barbara couldn't be here today senator
Mikulski she has done such a phenomenal
job and we have great leadership right
here in our chair in our co-chair but it
has been exciting and we look forward to
educating and celebrating with the women
of America well I just want to say that
this is a privilege to be your appointee
your nominee but also to work with this
great team and what I really like is the
zest and the energy and the enthusiasm
everybody showed in fact we just make it
impossible not to support this go from
100 to 300 it's that's a power of a lot
of women working together so thank you
mister it's an honor to be here I think
it's really important for us to remember
that all of us who are elected officials
who are women all of us who are serving
serve on the shoulders and the
accomplishments of so many women who
have come before us I'm very proud in
Wyoming of the strong women my mother my
grandmothers my great-grandmother's
and and just the tremendous work and
effort that went into this over the
years and so it's I think they're under
representing Senator Blackburn and
Jovita who you asked why this hadn't
gotten done before chavita basically
took a page from the Wollman Rink in new
york and overcame an awful lot of
process and obstacles to make sure that
something happened on time and in the
right way
this has been just a beautiful picture
of bipartisanship that I think many in
Congress could take a page from women of
every ilk were able to come together and
actually get something done so we hope
Congress we can thank you for your
leadership I think the four-letter word
leadership and really great team here at
the White House it has been working on
this
working very hard on those so thank you
very much it's a very important bill and
it's an honor to be involved with it and
I'm glad we got it done
[Applause]